go ah I know I know the city I was going
up very late and I'm sorry I've been in
this room nude head man my PEC was up so
the hate in your face mean like what I
thought you do it so I've been in this
room the past couple of days for most of
the day working on some secret chef that
I can't necessarily tell you guys about
but it's taken a lot of my time along
with doing planning for her no filter
shows why so I haven't had a chance to
properly explore London but I made my
director Jack very on one of my secret
projects that has brought me out here go
explore for me and he took a bunch of
photos of a lot of beautiful things and
he came back and he told me all about
them and I have listened but I think I
got the gist so here is a historical
tour of London this is the hotel we're
staying in we're not this is an old
house that's really ok this is the Globe
Theatre of classic where everyone in
London gets their Globes and maps and
other varieties of things this is Jack
very showing off that you can take a
panorama with this camera we get it Jack
what can your camera do this those are
all the people that Jack very clearly
did not want to get near very historical
that um two Big Ben's touching there is
classic historical London DMV very
historical this is Jack very Jesus Jack
White get out of here okay you're having
fun outside of a hotel
right that's the bus that almost hit
Jack ferry in his body very historical
this is a standoff of towers is what
they're called various storico this is
Jack loves the DMV this is another photo
of historical London DMV and then here
look at that London's oldest taxi run by
an invisible person oh this is where
they sell the puppies in London very
historical that is a the sewage system
and then this is the only school in
London no one here has education and
that is where they sell do drugs a
pharmacy this is the Running of the
Bulls very historical London and this
here is the Running of the Bulls also
whoa this is London's oldest dildo and
the first man that ever used it and this
is a dove that has exploded into flames
in the middle of a beautiful park that
is London's only working electrical lamp
very historical and that is London's
oldest cocktail the mojito I guess the
[ __ ] you're welcome for this thing you
didn't ask for I don't know